...
-Que vas-tu chanter ?
-"On s'embrasse,
on oublie tout".
-Si tu veux, tiens.
Frédéric, sois attentif.
-"On a chacun..
"..son caractère."
-Oh, oh !
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
-Je suis content.
-Tu pleurs
parce que tu es content ?
[Applaudissements.]
Viens là. C'est vrai ?
T'es content d'être là ?
Tu vas pleurer d'avantage,
parce qu'il y a plein de jouets.
Il faut rigoler
quand on est heureux.
Fais-moi voir comment tu rigoles.
Comment on fait pour rigoler ?
On fait comme ça.
-Non, pas comme ça.
-Comment on fait ?
-On rigole simple.
-Comment on fait
pour rigoler simple ?
Fais-moi un sourire, pour voir.
Tu es pas malheureux..
..de chanter ?
C'est parce que
tu es content de chanter ?
Alors, chante.
Tu veux que Frédéric François
vienne à côté de toi ?
-Non.
-Tu veux chanter seul ?
-Oui.
Je veux maman.
-Viens. Ben, viens !
Il pleur parce qu'il est heureux,
mais il a besoin de vous.
-On va chanter
tous les deux, hein ?
On est là pour chanter.
-Ne le frappez pas !
-Non, je ne vais pas le fapper.
-Tu chantes..
..avec ta maman ?
-Allez, on y va.
-Famille touchante !
[Applaudissements.]
Vas te mettre à côté.
-Je vais vous aider.
-"On a chacun..
"..son caractère.
"La paix devient..
"..soudain la guerre.
"Un mot entraîne l'autre..
"..on ne sait pourquoi.
"On se chamaille..."
-On ne va pas..
..faire pleurer un enfant.
Arrête !
Donnez un sucre.
C'est tout ce qu'il te faut ?
T'es heureux ?
-Oui.
-Fais-moi un sourire.
La troisième concurrente,
..toute souriante...
Elle a envie de rigoler.
C'est Sandra, numéro 2.
On l'applaudit.
Tu vas bien ?
-Oui.
-On se dit bonjour.
-Bonjour, Jacques Martin.
-Bonjour, Sandra.
On se fait un bisou ?
-Oui.
-D'où tu viens ?
-Hum... De...
De Noisiel,
au grand pays du chocolat.
-Tu habites dans un pays
où on fait du chocolat ?
Tu en manges beaucoup ?
-J'en sais rien, moi !
On n'en achète jamais !
-Vous n'achetez jamais
de chocolat, madame ?
Ton papa travaille..
..dans le chocolat ?
-Non.
Il est agent..
..de voyage.
-C'est un beau métier.
Ca me plairait d'avoir
un papa qui soit agent de voyage.
Tu as déjà voyagé ?
-Non, jamais,
..parce qu'il nous emmène jamais.
-Vous savez que c'est une fille
qui est très malheureuse !
-Il n'emmène jamais
mon petit-frère, moi et ma maman.
Alors que lui,
il s'en va tout seul en avion.
-Aurélie,
notre avant-dernière candidate..
..qui a du mal à descendre.
Je t'aides.
Ah, le micro est trop grande.
-Eh oh !
-Hein ?
-Alors tout le monde,
est-ce que ça va ?
[Applaudissements.]
Je vais faire une bise à l'autre.
-Elle va faire une bise à l'autre.
...
Pourquoi tu as embrassé..
..le petit garçon ?
-Parce que j'ai envie.
...
-Tu as failli me taper la tête !
-Non !
J'ai envie de faire un câlin.
-Vas-y !
Tu viens ?
Qu'est-ce que tu dis, là ?
Voilà.
Tu veux faire quoi plus tard ?
-Aïe !
-Ben oui !
Que veux-tu que je fasse ?
-Il a des boucles d'oreilles !
-Ah bon ?
Quelle chanson tu nous chante ?
Donnez-moi la première note.
-Aïe !
-Comment elle s'appelle
la chanson ?
-"Riri, Fifi et Loulou".
Tu as compris ou quoi ?
-Je vais chanter "Tous les enfants
chantent avec moi".
-J'ai le disque de toi.
-C'est bien, mon chéri.
-Tu la vois à la télévision
Mireille Mathieu.
-Des fois, pas souvent.
-Ah, pas souvent.
Elle est jolie, hein ?
-Oui.
-Tu te marierais avec elle ?
-Oh oui, ça oui !
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que je l'aime trop.
-Ah !
Alors, vas lui faire un bisou.
"Je l'aime trop".
Attention, restez sérieux.
Attendez les fiançailles.
Tu nous chante quoi, Nicolas ?
-"Tous les enfants..
"..chantent avec moi",
tu sais bien !
-Allez-y !
-"On m'a toujours dit..
"..qu'en chantant avec son coeur,
"..on faisait chanter le monde.
"Et je crois bien que c'est vrai."
-Ma 3e candidate et l'élégance
en personne, c'est Marynel.
Tu es venue avec qui ?
-Mon papa,
..ma maman,
..mon fiancé.
[Rires du public.]
-C'est lui ?
Viens, le fiancé.
Vous permettez
que je fasse connaissance..
..de la famille !
...
C'est ta fiancée ?
-Oui.
-Et c'est ton fiancé ?
-Alors, embrassez-vous.
-Ah non !
-Pourquoi ?
-On n'est pas encore mariés.
-Comment sont ses parents ?
Tu les trouves sympathiques ?
-Oui.
-Ta belle-mère est gentille ?
-Tenez, belle-maman,
..reprenez donc le mari !
-Tu es venu avec qui ?
-Avec mon papa,
..et ma tata,
puis tonton Xavier.
-Il m'a dit de venir maintenant.
J'attendais que vous m'appelez,
..et ça durait..
..trop longtemps..
..de venir vous voir !
-Tu voulais venir me voir.
Qu'est-ce que tu sais faire ?
-Je suis..
..en maternelle.
Je suis..
..en 3e classe.
-Tu peux m'aider, là ?
-Vous allez un peu m'aider,
et je vais un peu vous aider.
Mais avec vous.
-Bien sûr.
Comment tu t'appelles ?
-Nicolas.
-Je finis avec lui,
..et tu restes là,
tu vas m'aider.
Tu avais dit que tu m'aiderais ?
-Oui.
-Alors tu poses..
..les questions à ma place.
-Que voudras-tu faire plus tard ?
-Vétérinaire.
-C'est très bien.
[Rires du public.]
Tu pourras soigner..
..les animaux ?
-Oui.
-Je trouve ça bien !
-Nous allons accueillir
cette ravissante Vanessa.
Fais une grosse bise à Philippe.
Et vous l'applaudissez très fort.
On aurait dit que j'avais
préparé le micro pour toi.
Quel âge tu as ?
-7 ans.
-Tu habites où ?
-Villiers-sur-Marne.
-Tu es pas venue de très loin ?
-Non.
-Tu es venue en famille ?
-Oui.
-Tu nous la présente ?
-Ma maman, mon papa
et mon parrain.
-Où il est..
..ton papa ?
-Là.
-Le moustachu ?
-Oui.
-Elles piquent ses moustaches ?
-Non.
-Les papas ont toujours
des moustaches qui ne piquent pas.
Comment s'appelle ta maman ?
-Corinne.
-Bonjour, Corinne.
Ils travaillent..
..tous les deux ?
-Oui.
-Tu as des frères et des soeurs ?
-Non.
-Tu aimerais avoir..
..des frères et des soeurs ?
-Oui.
-Combien tu en voudrais ?
-Une seule.
-Voilà, vous voyez
ce qui vous reste à faire !
J'ai l'impression, comme ça,
que tu fais un peu de danse.
Tu fais un peu de danse, non ?
-Oui.
-De la danse classique ?
-Rythmique.
-Fais-moi voir..
comment on fait
de la danse rythmique.
Comme ça ?
C'est pas comme ça ?
Tu ne veux pas me montrer ?
-Non.
-Tu veux chanter,
..quand même ?
-Oui.
"Emilie Jolie et le grand oiseau".
-"Emilie Jolie".
C'était celle que j'attendais.
Vas-y.
...
-"Je m'appelle Emilie Jolie.
"Je m'appelle Emilie Jolie.
"Je voudrais partir avec vous..
"..tout au bout du ciel,
"..sur vos ailes.
"Et je voudrais vivre avec vous..
"..ma vie.
"Tu t'appelles Emilie Jolie.
"Tu voudrais partir..
"..avec nous..
"..tout au bout du ciel,
"..sur nos ailes.
"Et tu voudrais vivre
avec nous..
"..ta vie.
"Oui, c'est ça,
vous m'avez compris.
"Alors, dites-moi oui.
"Tu t'appelles Emilie Jolie.
"Tu rêves de voler la nuit,
"..partir rejoindre le soleil,
"..et même la lune,
"..sur nos plumes.
"Et tu voudrais vivre avec nous..
"..ta vie.
"Oui, c'est ça,
vous m'avez compris.
"Alors, dites-moi oui.
"Mais il y a tant de choses
à voir avant..
"..de partir pour le firmament.
"Il y a tant de pages à tourner.
"Ta vie ne fait que commencer.
"Il y a tant de choses
à voir avant..
"..de partir pour le firmament.
"Il y a tant de jours
et tant de nuits.
"Tu es au début de ta vie."
-Formidable !
Vraiment touchante.
Viens voir.
Tu sais ce que me disait..
..l'auteur de cette chanson ?
Que cette petite fille chante..
..très, très juste.
Tu fais de la musique ?
-Oui, du piano.
-Ah, c'est pour ça.
On l'applaudit très fort,
..et on lui donne une note.
Philippe, tu es très attentif.
Sir Cédric.
Tu choisis ce que tu veux.
Voilà.
Tu aimes bien manger ?
-Oui.
-Qu'est-ce que tu préfères ?
-J'aime le cassoulet.
-Dans le Nord,
..c'est normal. Et puis ?
-Quand maman fait du cassoulet,
moi je pète toujours la nuit.
-Tu fais ?
-Je pète toujours la nuit..
..quand je mange du cassoulet.
-Tu fais quoi la nuit ?
-Je pète.
-Ah bon ?
-Oui.
-Pourquoi ?
-Ca fait péter,
..le cassoulet !
-C'est pour ça..
..que tu aimes le cassoulet ?
-Oui.
-Ca rit quand même.
Et ça, c'est marrant ?
-Oui.
-Il y a que toi
à qui ça arrive..
..dans la famille ?
-Non.
-Qui est-ce qui pète encore ?
-Il y a papa,
puis Christelle.
-C'est une famille..
..qui pète !
[Elle rit.]
Tu manges à la cantine
ou chez maman ?
-Je mange beaucoup à la cantine
et un peu chez maman.
-On mange quoi à la cantine ?
-On mange..
..toujours un...
Non, pas du cassoulet !
-Il fait quoi papa comme métier ?
-Il est "rouleur".
Il conduit le camion.
-Ah, il est "rouleur" !
Et maman, elle fait quoi ?
-La machine.
-La machine à quoi ?
-La machine pour faire du "rouleur".
-Il y en a un
qui a compris, au moins !
Tu as des frères et des soeurs ?
-Eh ben, j'ai...
trois copains,
un frère et une soeur.
-Tu as des frères et des soeurs ?
-Non,
..j'en veux pas !
-Et pourquoi donc ?
-Ca ne me plaît pas.
-Il est là,
..le parrain ?
-Non,
..il ne peut pas venir,
il a un contrôle fiscal.
-Notre dernier candidat,
Yohann. Viens,
..Yohann.
Où ils sont tes parents ?
Bonjour, monsieur l'électricien.
Il a une moustache.
-Et ma maman...
-Qui n'a pas de moustache !
-Elle est cachée.
-Elle est cassée ?
-Non, cachée derrière le monsieur.
-Je l'ai vue.
-Mais elle a enlevé
ses lunettes..
..parce qu'elle n'en voulait pas.
-Elle ne voulait pas..
..qu'on sache qu'elle porte
des lunettes. Vous pouvez..
..les remettre, maintenant !
Elle porte des lunettes..
..d'habitude. Et là, elle les a
enlevées pour pas qu'on voit.
Comment c'est son petit nom ?
-Sylviane.
-Et papa ?
-Jean-Paul.
-Il a une bonne bouille,
Jean-Paul.
-Il boit de l'eau ou du vin ?
-Du vin.
-C'est un copain à moi !
Combien..
..il boit par jour ?
-Deux, trois litres.
-Ca va !
Mon copain !
Trois litres par jour !
Autant que 2 cheveux !
Toi, tu ne bois pas de vin ?
-Non, je bois du sirop.
-Maman boit du vin, un peu ?
-Oui, un petit peu.
-Combien de litre ?
-C'est pareil que lui.
-Monsieur Christophe
qu'on applaudit très fort.
Christophe, quel âge tu as ?
-6 ans.
-Je te baisse un peu le micro.
C'est la bonne hauteur, là ?
Fais un essaie.
Han han !
-Han han !
-Fais un essaie là-dedans.
On dirait un homme politique.
Tu regardes la télévision,
en ce moment ?
-Oui.
-Qu'est-ce que tu en pense..
..de tous ces hommes politiques
qui n'arrêtent pas de parler ?
-Ils font que parler.
Je sais faire
les pépés des Muppets.
-Fais-moi voir comment ils font.
-"T'as vu la belle femme ?
Ouai, elle est belle !"
[Rires et applaudissements.]
-Ca, c'est formidable.
Faites-moi un gros plan
sur notre artiste.
Refais-moi les pépés des Muppets,
je n'ai pas entendu.
-"Eh, t'as vu la belle femme ?
Ah ouai, elle est belle !"
"Toi, t'as ta chaise,
elle est à moitié craquée !"
-C'est certainement le plus grand.
A n'en pas douter,
c'est l'aîné.
Ouh la la, qu'il est grand !
Ouh qu'il est grand !
C'est Eric.
Ouh qu'il est grand, Eric !
On applaudit Eric.
Quel âge tu as, Eric ?
-5 ans.
-Combien ?
-Ben dis donc !
5 ans ?
C'est étonnant.
Que tu es grand pour 5 ans !
Fais voir ton papa
si il est aussi grand.
Dis donc, ton papa
est plus petit que toi !
-Il est grand, très grand.
-Combien il mesure ?
-Heu... 5 mètres.
-5 mètres ?
-Oui.
-C'est un monsieur...
Vous devez avoir du mal
à vous habiller en confection.
Et ta maman ?
-Six.
-6 mètres !
Dites-moi, chère madame,
voilà une grande famille !
Et tu as un frère ?
-Non.
-Pas de frère, pas de soeur ?
-J'ai un chien.
-Et combien il mesure ?
-6 francs.
-"6 francs".
Notre 3e candidate,
Mlle Sylvie,
..que je vous demande
de l'applaudir bien fort.
Tu es venue toute seule
ou avec ta famille ?
-Avec ma famille.
-Dis-moi qui c'est.
-C'est mon papa, ma maman
et ma mamie.
-Où ils sont ?
-Là-bas.
-Comment il s'appelle papa ?
-Freddy.
-Freddy ?
-Mais oui.
-Je le connait Freddy.
Que fait-il comme métier ?
-Gendarme, et il y a
deux, trois gendarmes..
..qui sont ici.
-Il est gendarme Freddy ?!
-Oui, mais les autres gendarmes,
..à la gendarmerie,
..ils boivent quelques fois
des pintes.
-Ils boivent des pintes,
à la gendarmerie ?
-Ils sont des buveurs !
-Ah, c'est des buveurs !
On en apprend bien
sur les gendarmes !
On apprend très fort Benjamin.
Benjamin, vas-y.
Je vais monter le micro.
Quel âge tu as ?
-6 ans.
-6 ans. Fais voir
presque toutes tes dents.
Fais un gros sourire
à la caméra.
Il y en manque 2.
-Mon papa m'a dit
que tu me fais pas trop sourire.
-A cause de quoi ?
-Parce que
j'ai 2 dents perdues.
-N'aie pas peur.
Tu es beau
quand tu souris.
En gros plan,
..fais un grand sourire.
-Non.
-C'est bien d'obéir à son papa.
Il fait quoi ton papa
comme métier ?
-Inspecteur des impôts,
mais un inspecteur gentil.
-Quel âge tu as ?
5 ans ? Tu as des petits-frères
et des petites-soeurs ?
-Non, mais je voudrais..
..un petit frère.
-Tout de suite ?
-Oui.
Pour la semaine prochaine ?
-Oui mais il y a plus..
..de gouttes qui tombent.
[Rires du public.]
[Propos inintelligible.]
-Avec qui tu es venue ?
-Avec ma maman,
..mon papa..
..et des amis.
-Fais-moi voir papa.
-Papa il est là-bas.
-Alors les gouttes...
Il fait quoi comme métier ?
-Il est chez Mamie Nova,
et puis...
-Ah, il est chez Mamie Nova !
-Il travaille chez Mamie Nova
et il fait des yaourts.
-Alors il n'a plus de gouttes !
-Mais les gouttes
ne sont pas à Nova !
-Ah bon ?
Où qu'elles sont ?
-Il faut que ça tombe
dans le ventre tout seul.
-On applaudit bien fort Stéphanie.
Tu viens de Sète.
C'est un pays que j'adore.
Avec qui tu es venue ?
-Avec mon papa,
..ma maman..
..et moi.
Maman travaille..
..à la maison.
-Qui c'est qui fait les lits ?
-C'est maman,
..et moi ici, à Paris,
..c'est moi qui veut
faire le mien.
Mais comme papa a couché
dans mon lit, cette nuit...
-Papa a couché
dans ton lit, cette nuit ?
-Oui, et moi j'ai couché
dans le lit de ma maman.
-Ah !
Tu vas à l'église ?
-Non.
-Tu ne fais jamais ta prière ?
-Heu... j'en sais rien.
-"Petit Jésus,
je vous donne mon coeur."
Tu ne sais pas qui c'est
le petit Jésus.
Il habites pas Sète ?
-Si.
-Il habite Sète ?
-Je ne sais pas où il habite,
mais il doit habiter Sète.
-Johan !
Ca va Johan ? Tu vas bien ?
J'ai tout de suite vu que tu étais
un garçon. Quel âge tu as ?
-4 ans.
J'ai jamais vu quelqu'un avoir
des gros bras comme ça.
Tu fais du sport ?
Qu'est-ce que tu fais comme sport ?
-Du boxe.
-Fais voir comment t'en fais.
Hou la la !
Refais voir.
Hou ! Qu'est-ce que t'es fort !
Fais-moi voir ta maman.
C'est la dame blonde ?
Et c'est ton petit-frère
qui est devant ?
-Oui.
-Et lui aussi il sait boxer ?
-Non.
-Alors, c'est toi qui gagne.
C'est formidable.
Viens voir, viens voir.
Viens voir, toi.
Non, vous allez pas boxer !
Ha ha ha !
Quel malin !
Ben dis donc !
Stop "break" !
"Break" !
Quel boxeur !
Vous jouez à la boxe,
tous les deux ?
Tu nous chante quoi ?
-"Prince d'amour".
-Formidable, on va l'écouter.
-"Je serai ton prince d'amour.
"Je te protégerai toujours.
"Il ne faut pas
que tu sois triste."
-Vas-y. 1, 2, 3 !
Houla ! Houla !
Vous comprenez
que c'est ça.
Viens, Alexandre.
Hop ! Hop !
Vas-y, Alexandre.
1, 2, 3.
[Musique rythmique au piano.]
...
Je vais te dire,
Hallyday n'a qu'à se tenir !
Tu suces ton pouce,
..Alexandre ?
-Non.
-T'as jamais sucé ton pouce ?
-Si.
-Quand ?
-Toute la nuit.
-Ah oui !
Fais voir comment tu fais.
C'est drôle, ça.
Tu suces pas ton pouce,
mais les 2 doigts du milieu.
Tu sais siffler ?
[Alexandre Siffle.]
Voilà un garçon
complètement complet.
Où sont tes parents ?
-C'est celui..
..qui lève le doigt.
-A quoi il ressemble ?
-Ben, à rien.
-A rien, oui !
Jean-Paul, j'ai dit que tu étais
mon copain, parce que j'ai vu..
..que tu savais faire des grimaces.
-Oui.
-"Oui".
Tu veux me faire
quelques grimaces ?
Je vais essayer de refaire la même.
Tu me diras si c'est bien.
Non.
On va faire un concours de grimace.
A toi de commencer.
Moi, j'en fais une autre.
Comment tu la trouve ?
-Moche.
[Rire général.]
-Ma grimace est moche ?
-Oui.
[Sheila.]
-Fais une autre, toi.
-Je vais essayer de la faire.
Comment tu trouves ?
-Moche.
-Que vas-tu..
..chanter ?
-Pipi !
-Hein ?
-C'est pas grave.
-J'ai mis des chaussures
toutes neuves, en plus.
Ca va les salir.
-C'est pas grave, ça.
-Hein ?
-Mon pantalon, il tient.
Je ne pense pas..
..que ça coulera
sur mes chaussures..
..si je me tiens comme ça.
-Ca ne se voit pas
que t'as fais pipi.
Et puis les chaussures,
ça va sécher.
-Non, ça séchera pas.
C'est des chaussures en bois.
En carton.
-C'est des chaussures en carton ?
-Oui.
-Tu as fais pipi,
..maintenant.
Qu'est-ce que tu chantes ?
-"Tu es venu".
-Hein ?
...
-Quel âge tu as, Cédric ?
-4 ans et demi.
-Que tu es grand pour 4 ans et demi.
Et tu habites où ?
-En France.
-Tu habites en France.
Quelle rue ?
-Rue de la Bulle Celtique.
-Tu vas à l'école, Cédric ?
-J'y vais qu'à 5 ans.
-Donc tu vas commencer.
Tu n'a pas encore été ?
-Non.
-Et tu voudrais y aller ?
-Un petit peu.
-Tu préférerais rester à la maison..
..ou aller à l'école ?
-Rester à la maison avec maman.
-Tu as des petits frères
et des petites soeurs ?
-Ben, j'ai...
trois copains,
un frère et une soeur.
[Applaudissements.]
-Et vous jouez tous les quatre..
..ensemble ?
-Des fois..
..avec le frère,
..des fois la soeur,
..ou des fois
les trois copains.
-Et ta soeur est plus grande
ou plus petite que toi ?
-Elle a le même âge que moi.
-Ah ! Le même âge que toi,
vous êtes nés le même jour ?
Où sont tes parents ?
-Là.
-Comment elle s'appelle ta maman ?
-Jacqueline.
-Bonjour, Jacqueline. Et ton papa ?
-Heu...
Je réfléchi,
parce que c'est un peu...
Jusepe.
-"Juisepe".
-Non, "Ju".
-Jusepe.
C'est un prénom italien, ça.
Tu manges des pâtes,
..chez toi ?
-Oui.
-Tous les jours ?
-Pas tellement.
-Qu'est-ce que tu voudras
faire plus tard ?
-"Maquetteur" de vaisseau spatial.
-C'est la 1re fois
que j'entends cette profession.
Tu veux être quoi ?
-"Maquetteur" de vaisseau spatial.
-C'est un métier formidable.
Tu sais déjà faire des maquettes..
..de vaisseau spatial ?
-Non, quand je serai grand.
-Tu voudras aller dans la lune ?
Ca te plairait d'être un cosmonaute
et de monter dans le ciel ?
-Ca, non.
-Pourquoi ?
-Parce que je sais pas trop
piloter un vaisseau spatial.
-Mais c'est très facile à apprendre.
-Oui, mais je sais déjà..
..faire des vaisseaux spatiaux
en lego avec les pions.
-Tu sais faire
les vaisseaux spatiaux en légo ?
Tu as dit bonjour à François ?
Ah, excuse-moi.
J'ai connu ton père
à l'âge de ce garçon.
Fais une grosse bise
à Philippe Chatel.
Que vas-tu chanter,
..Cédric ?
-"Le hérisson".
-Et comment c'est fait
un hérisson ?
-Une bête ronde
avec des petites pattes,
..un nez pointu
et des piquants sur le dos.
-Ah bon ?
Tu en as déjà vu ?
-Ah non.
-Alors tu vas nous chanter
"Le hérisson". Vas-y.
-"Oh, qu'est-ce qui pique,
"..ce hérisson !
"Oh,
"..qu'elle est triste sa chanson.
"Oh, qu'est-ce qui pique,
"..ce hérisson.
"Oh, qu'elle est triste sa chanson.
-"C'est un hérisson...
-"C'est un hérisson..
"..qui piquait, qui piquait,
"..et qui voulait
qu'on le caresse, resse, resse.
"On le caresse pas,
pas, pas, pas, pas,
"..non pas parce qu'il piquait pas,
mais parce qu'il piquait.
"C'est un hérisson
qui piquait, qui piquait,
"..et qui voulait
qu'on le caresse, resse, resse.
"On le caresse pas,
pas, pas, pas, pas,
"..non pas parce qu'il piquait pas,
mais parce qu'il piquait.
-"Oh, qu'est-ce qui pique...
-"Le hérisson.
"Oh, qu'elle est triste
sa chanson."
-Tu aimes les films d'horreur ?
-Oui.
Papa a enregistré
un beau film d'horreur.
-Lequel ?
-C'est un film...
C'est un film de l'araignée.
Elle était petite.
Après, il y avait
une dame qui a parlé,
..et puis il y avait
une dame qui était vieille.
C'était une mère à quelqu'un.
Et puis la dame a crié :
"C'est l'araignée !
C'est l'araignée !"
Et puis elle s'est transformée..
..en grosse araignée.
-Grosse comment ?
-Comme ça.
-Plus grosse que moi ?
-T'as eu peur ?
-Non, parce que
j'aime bien les films d'horreur.
-Ah !!!
-Et on a vu un bonhomme
qui n'a pas eu peur.
Il avait un pistolet.
Il y a essayé avec son pistolet,
il ne peut rien faire.
Il a fait un feu,
..il l'a jeté sur elle..
..et elle était toute brûlée.
-L'araignée ?
-Oui, la grosse araignée.
-Elle meurt,
..à la fin ?
-Eh ben...
-Elle est morte à la fin ?
-Non, elle marchait un peu..
..pour essayer de les attraper
dans le feu.
Ils ont couru,
ils ont fermé la porte,
..et tout explosait.
-C'est un beau film.
On peut l'applaudir.
-Et à la fin...
Ils ont oublié une fille..
..qui avait un coeur rouge.
Et puis, d'un seul coup,
..c'était une araignée.
La fille, c'était
une toute petite araignée.
Et le bonhomme est tombé
dans un trou,
..mais il n'était pas mort.
Il attendait.
Il était pas mort.
Mais d'un seul coup,
..c'était un vieux
qui a fait un trou..
..pour voir
si c'étaient des méchants.
Mais c'était un gentil..
..qui cherchait l'araignée.
Alors, il a vu une toile
faite par l'araignée.
Et puis il l'a jeté..
..dans un trou.
[Applaudissements.]
Après, après...
[Rire général.]
Et puis après
il était pas mort.
Il croyait qu'il était mort.
Mais il y a des araignées..
..qui demandaient à la dame
si il était méchant.
Elles étaient dessus.
Il y avait beaucoup
qui étaient dessus.
-Bravo !
Tu parles un peu alsacien ?
-Non, mais je connais une chanson.
-Tu peux me la chanter ?
-Oui.
[Elle chante en alsacien,
"D'r Hans im Schnokeloch".]
...
-Elle n'a pas fait
une faute d'alsacien.
-Comment ?
-Il n'y a pas de faute
dans mon texte alsacien.
-Aucune faute.
Ca se danse, ça.
Fais voir comment on danse.
-Il faut danser à deux.
-On va le faire tout les 2.
Montre-moi. Vas-y.
-Il faut tourner en rond
et donner la main.
-D'accord. Vas-y.
["D'r Hans im Schnokeloch"
au piano.]
...
C'est très bien. La danse
folklorique, si on l'apprend pas...
Is you speak english ?
[Le petit garçon..]
[..répond dans un anglais
inhabituel.]
...
-Oui, je me trompe !
Toi, habites où ?
-A Pantin.
[Fous rire général.]
-Comment s'appelle la chanson ?
-"Les jolies cartes postales".
-Eh ben voilà !
Si il veut, il peut traduire.